zelenski calls for preemptive strikes
from NATO to keep Russia from using
nukes uh-huh okay whatever man
zlinski says it's time for world war
three everyone should burn in a reign of
nuclear Hellfire he didn't really say
that but he may have what may as well
have said that velodimir zielinski
called on NATO to conduct preemptive
strikes against Russian targets to
prevent their use of nuclear weapons in
Ukraine which literally would do the
opposite I okay that that's it I kind of
feel like he's actually just saying you
know it's the waiting I can't stand just
burn it all to the ground because no one
no sane rational person thinks a
preemptive strike against Russia would
result in anything other than them
launching nuclear weapons so this is
zielinski was throwing like people in
like I think he shut down
um
TV stations three the three largest TV
stations in Ukraine I think you had them
shut down because they were and not
against them and political parties as
well that were against him yeah he's not
a good guy he's maybe was an actor so
he's got some Charisma but I don't think
he's like a benevolent president by any
means during a time of War all the rules
are out of the window so you know we
have to understand we're not fighting
for democracy here this is not a
democracy but he shut those TV stations
down before any Russian I believe it was
during the I believe it was because of
of the war and the emergency powers that
the government got but again all rules
everything's off the table once there's
a war and that's how he's treating the
situation his statements today I mean
he's trying to you know walk them back
as much as he can he's trying to say
that he wanted to really call for
preemptive sanctions but there's a big
distinction between preemptive strikes
and preemptive sanctions and he was
specifically talking to an Australian
Think Tank the lowly institution and
these are Big statements the Russians
are coming out and saying well these
statements risk another world war and
and these are very dangerous statements
and this is the trajectory that we are
on unless there's some actual
de-escalation detonte and some real
civil conversations that could actually
pull us away from this lunacy you mean
like Elon Musk yes at least at least
he's trying his proposal wasn't perfect
but at least he tried at least he
started the conversation and now lunatic
Lindsey Graham the chicken hawk that he
is is saying that he's going to be taken
away his uh his tax credits which he
never got for his Tesla company he never
even had someone's gotta try someone's
got to try to de-escalate I I guess I
also wonder like why is he asking why is
he asking NATO to do a preemptive strike
so let's get like 50 billion dollars
worth of weapons why why is he doing it
there are three Democrats who have now
publicly stated that the greatest
National Security objective for the
United States is to defeat Russia in
Ukraine I think they came out and said
it yo we're at war with Russia they're
just playing this game it's not for
Russia's benefit Russia knows we're at
war with them it's because it's illegal
because what they're doing violates the
Constitution they did not get
Congressional approval for this so
they're going to dance around like you
know you know people ask you've got
you've got U.S Personnel veterans on the
ground in Ukraine we now have
confirmation from The Intercept that U.S
boots are actually doing Special
Operations on the ground at what point
are we just like okay dudes we get it
you declared war on Russia
but that's the game Vladimir Putin knows
full well what NATO and the US are doing
there
they're lying saying it's just veterans
being supplied and trained by us and
then delivering weapons and training to
the ukrainians there only was no saying
that is because they're not legally
allowed to do it and they did so
criminals criminals in the in the
government
yeah that never happened before uh musk
made another statement today when he was
attacked by the Kiev post he said uh
look I love Ukraine but not World War
III and I think that's the sentiment for
the majority of people right now looking
at this situation rationally as we're
not really you know this conversation
it's it's shared about online but when
we look at the mainline coverage this is
not really talked about as much as
significantly the corporate media right
now is focusing on two Russians that
swam to Alaska to avoid the mobilization
that seems to be that the biggest kind
of story that you see on the main
headline television networks but you
don't really hear about the dangerous
implications you don't really hear
anti-war voices you don't really hear
anything contrary other than we need War
let's play chicken nuclear war because
it's fun somehow and that's that's
insane for the record they uh zielinski
shut down three TV stations in February
of 21 2021 a year before Putin dated and
they were like pro-russia according to
him was like oh it's Russia so they've
really been at like a pseudo Wharf since
2014 I mean since Putin Annex Crimea
that was pretty overt you guys know that
the U.S had an office of censorship
during World War II yeah yeah silence
accelerates victory was their slogan The
Motto I guess well we played Japanese
and internment camps too I mean yeah
that's right you know as a part of the
world well information is key and you
know many times there was accusations
against Germans there was accusations
against Japanese citizens that were
providing allegedly information to the
enemy and the United States took it as
far as to literally set up camps for
Japanese people to be interned in which
was a step too far and I think you know
during these situations during emergency
situations we should always be careful
not to take a step too far and we have
done it time and time again I'm watching
this video or I have been of uh like
volunteers on the ground in Ukraine
American guy goes over with a helmet cam
and he's recording it as he's running
around fighting like they're in combat
and they don't know who they're fighting
they don't know where the enemy is
they're just being told by a squad
leader who's like a french guy or like
some Ukrainian dude they got a
friendship so they just go place they
wait and then they're like if someone
tells them speaking of information being
important if someone says that's the
enemy fire they'll just start shooting
they don't know yep yeah how many how
many uh Ukrainian citizens you think
joined with the Russians something that
they don't talk about in Western media
but but of course they did especially in
the East they probably said you know
we're with you know Russia on this one
otherwise I mean they wouldn't have it's
just the output I'll leave it at that my
question and the reason I bring that up
is do you believe the Western media that
Ukraine is winning
this is a I think a topic worth
discussing because we might see opposing
viewpoints on this as we were kind of
talking about the subject before the
show there's there's a lot of
circumstantial evidence there's there's
the understanding that there's a lot of
propaganda a lot of disinformation but
we also have to understand that the
ukrainians were practicing and drilling
for this ever since 2014 on their
territory they have the latest
technology they have night vision they
have thermal they have satellite
technology they have GPS coordinated uh
weapon systems they have training from
CIA covert Ops Special Forces soldiers
that were there since 2014 setting up
the groundwork for this Invasion as the
U.S corporate media was literally
cheering on and setting the groundwork
to make everyone hate Russia so this has
been in the works for a very long time
and I do believe
from just my initial perspectives from
what I've seen and I know people are
going to attack me I got attacked last
week because I said the ukrainians are
going to take the city of Lyman the
ukrainians did take the city of Lyman
but from my perspective looking at the
telegram channels seeing footage from
the Russians and the ukrainians it does
seem especially right now that the
ukrainians are getting back a lot of the
territory and are having some
significant victories against what looks
like a disorganized force with the
Russians that's my perspective in my
opinion and I could be wrong and I know
I'm going to get you know for it I don't
believe the propaganda but it's also not
the ukrainians it's NATO NATO is winning
back these cities
yeah and also Russia Russia's not fully
engaged as far as I can tell from what
I've heard I mean they have not
committed their entire military he just
raised another 300 000 people uh drafted
I think they drafted
mobilization well in the mobilization
there's also a secret paragraph that
hasn't been released to the general
public uh but but also Russia is facing
stiff declines in their population just
like the majority of the Western World
Taiwan uh the ministry of Defense
actually came out today and also said
that they have a huge problem because of
the low birth rate they're not going to
have anyone to join the military soon so
Russia is also facing a very similar
problem
um and and you know how many people are
fleeing that's that's contested there's
a lot of disinformation there's a lot of
propaganda and a lot of it is just
censored centered around Russia bad uh
the war they're losing at 100 that's not
the 100 Truth uh out of the situation
but again we're in a war the reporting
has been just propaganda and that's
exactly what it is from now on well do
you think that it's possible that the
fact that Putin is talking about nuclear
weapons is a sign that maybe he is
losing yeah
I think that's a better indication to me
than anything coming out of the media
just I don't know if he'd be talking
like that if if losing losing though to
the degree that he's engaged I mean the
question is has has Russia utilized all
of their their forces to the maximum
capability obviously no because they
have nukes and then the question is okay
well aside from nukes then are they
using their Ground Forces well no they
just mobilized another 300 000 they
could certainly conscript more people so
they've not even maximized in terms of
ground troops and then it's
if they really wanted to to declare
full-scale war I mean they don't even
have to use icbms they have our there's
a bunch of weapons they could and
haven't used there was video going out
of them dropping incendiary bombs on a
city why have they not done that in
larger numbers on other cities because
it looks like Russia is actually
restrained right now it looks like
there's a lot of supply shortages it
looks like a lot of their main routes
have been met with a lot of resistance
and there's also a lot of video footage
showing you know Russians fighting with
you know regular red book bags fighting
with no uh armor at all fighting with
old equipment so again how much of how
much of that is propaganda how much of
it is real but I've seen similar reports
and similar videos from uh you know the
Russian side showing them fighting
having victories but but still a lot of
them are under equipped a lot of them
don't have any body armor at all I think
there was an expectation that they would
move in from the East and that the
people in Ukraine would open their arms
and be like kind of like what happened
in Crimea be like well elf thank you now
we're we're liberated we're back as part
of Russia we used to you know they were
they used to be part of Russia before
the Soviet Union was split up at all of
Ukraine and but they he that it was
underestimated the amount of
psychological propaganda that have been
proliferated in Ukraine and and pro-west
pro liberal economic order and there was
just massive psychological resistance
they you know everyone a lot of people
thought zelinski was going to flee as
soon as the invasion was announced but
he was like no I'm staying probably
because psychologically he was prepared
because of all this NATO influence but
also Russia hasn't fully declared it as
a war they're describing it as a limited
Military operation uh so so we have to
understand attacks on the infrastructure
weren't made by the Russians the
Russians could take out the electricity
the power the water and a lot of other
uh especially with their control of of
the the nuclear facility inside of
Ukraine they haven't done that yet so I
think they're still holding back some
cards that will make a greater impact on
this conflict not just nuclear warheads
but uh a declaration of a full all-out
War thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at at 8pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there